Oh what is going on YouTube oh [ __ ] is
your first near College from our
collection a lot of you have started or
just went back to get your education oh
man well doesn't that suck camel dick
for those of you who just started
college the freshman and I'm scared
shitless no need to be scared already
is that French what the [ __ ] I'm going
to give you a crash course on how to
survive your freshman year your little
nervous [ __ ] so you already know what
it is maybe let's get that first day of
dorms introduce yourself I understand
that some of you out there on shot and
spa but on the first day of college now
it's not the time now if you like
children your room Devon topping anyone
just touching yourself in the corner
then by all means whack away but in a
couple of months don't call back home to
your parents crying mommy
nobody likes me here at Hogwarts when
you never attempted to introduce
yourself to your peers walk out with
chin up go around the doors and say hey
my name is David what's your thing
and if they don't like you then you say
[ __ ] anybody want to be your friend
anyways we're looking at [ __ ]
[ __ ] in order for you to even create
friendships you gotta be open enough to
at least introduce yourself
relationships
please don't get with the guy or girl
that lives in your dorm do you realize
that when you do that you gotta see
their sorry faces every day for the rest
of the first year trophy player you
don't want some breathing room every
nowaday
cuz lord knows you can't break up then
when they're living with you hey baby I
don't think this is working out so um I
think we should just kind of you know
about see the mom cuz I live at you and
[ __ ] so chill out with that [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] 18 years old your balls just
dropped experience college through your
own eyes and quit trying to settle down
the moment you get on campus
ladies same thing for you and maybe even
worse because young
the age of 18 have jealousy issues this
means that he is gonna try to control
you wherever you go and trust me you
guys are gonna fight bet they can we
talk for a second yeah uh I saw you
children gym the other day what was that
now uh he's my lab partner [ __ ] so he
was all up in your pesto's daddy guy I
ain't say it but you gotta study this
ain't high school where you get the [ __ ]
around and copy people's homework and
you're good to roll in college homework
doesn't do [ __ ]
oh the homework is done as a learning
aid which prepares you for your exams
which accounts for most of your grades
look here stupid if they raising your
GPA is a lot harder than dropping your
GPA how do I know this I found this [ __ ]
the hard way but 2.2 next year straight
game base straight A's this year let's
see my GPA two point four mother always
sign up for your class on time if you
don't you'll be stuck with the most
shittiest most useless classes with the
professors that just learn how to speak
English the other day ah business and I
hooked up with an econ teacher who I
swore was speaking to me in Hindi for
three months straight
to be honest with you I should notice on
the first day when he introduced his
last name and it was like the whole
[ __ ] alphabet go fast my name
is Professor Hottel cooped up I'm Missy
the [ __ ] indian busta rhymes what huh
you got to work out a little bit that
Freshman Fifteen [ __ ] is no joke
personally I don't have a freshman 15
I had a freshman 40 I was walking around
looking like Yanis Korean cousin eat
hummus well people follow these rules
for your first year college egg you
should be fine your undergrad at college
should be the most memorable four years
of your life or in my case a lot more
than four years it was like looks like
six or seven you know what you don't
even know this just turn it off if later
on tonight I ask you to be my girlfriend
right know what I want
this isn't [ __ ]